[Music]
please
hit us up
[Music]
stay still
get out of here
[Music]
fear is a tool
when that light hits the sky
[Music]
it's not just a call
it's a warning
[Music]
i've been trying to reach you
before the god
this is about a king
and river is the match
i can take care of myself
if this continues it won't be long
before you've nothing left
i don't care what happens to me
it's only going to get worse for you
oh take it easy sweetheart
hear everything they say
maybe we're not so different
who are you under there
i'm vengeance
and blue
and dead
all over
dick
i got you
[Music]
there are places out there you can't
find on any map
they're not gone
they're just lost
hey kid i'm a little young for a
bartender aren't you a little old for
prom aren't you
falling all around
everything in here why the map this path
ferdinand magellan took the sail around
the world you know your history
it's the biggest treasure that's never
been found 5 billion easy
to go i think you're here because you're
your brother well you know my brother
said
who the hell is this i'm a friend of
sully's sally doesn't have any friends i
should know him one of them
you're a collector well i dabbled i
don't know
my family has been looking for this
person for a very long time so much
blood
i'm pretty sure he's just threatening to
kill me but don't touch your ear like
that you look like an idiot
you have no idea who you partnered with
i've been dreaming about this stuff
since i was a kid my brother's saying
that one final clue
oh god
[Music]
oh my god i should never come out to
play with that big boy's way in cause
you're about to get a proper scottish
welcome
what
oh crap
exclusively in movie theaters
[Music]
tell me something
[Music]
you can go
anywhere you want right
any timeline
in the universe
[Music]
why do you want to stay
and fight to save this one
you change the future
and you change the past
are you in
the outsiders ravage our lands
their cruelty to my people is all i've
known
so you're going tomorrow yes i'm going
to my office advancing i'd like you to
take me with you
are you trying to give me commercials
can i trust you something
i've been having dreams
about a girl
fallen in battle
felt like a vision
dreams make good stories but everything
important happens when we're awake
to the future of house of tradies
you have to be ready
there is no call we do not answer there
is no faith that we betray
they're not human they're brutal
what if i'm not dead you'll still be the
only thing i ever needed you to beat
come on
[Music]
listen
i know you
tonight the bloodline ends forever
kill them all
this is an extermination
they're taking my family off one by one
only together
[Music]
can we stand a chance let's fight like
demons
it's not safe for you here
i must not fear
fear is the mind killer
the fear is gone
[Music]
this is only the beginning
hmm
this isn't funny amber would you like to
play a game tara
[Laughter]
doors unlocked
all doors locked
doors unlocked
hello
it's happening
three attacks so far do you have a gun
i'm sydney prescott of course i have a
gun
something about this one just feels
different
samantha
i'm i know who you are i've been through
this
a lot
this is your life now which means that
whoever this is is gonna keep coming for
you
[Music]
are you ready
for this
there are certain rules to surviving
the attacks were all on people related
to the original killers
whatever his link is to our past
it's pulled us all back here
and i won't sleep until he's in the
ground
[Music]
an
hello
every story has a beginning
discover the origin of evil
[Music]
why are you back here clear your
conspiracies weren't true when we were
kids they're not true now
we need to expose umbrella
watch this
i'm afraid claire i'm afraid of what
they're gonna do to this town
see an umbrella they have an incident
i'm talking chernobyl if you know what i
mean
people are getting sick
you gotta help us claire let the world
know what's really going on
[Music]
shall we go
[Music]
doing here this is right here
experimenting on them
should split up
[Music]
we gotta get out of here
[Music]
we're gonna take umbrella down
[Applause]
you're a great mom
i don't know i'm fine with trevor
but with phoebe
she really keeps me on the outside
that's normal she's an awkward nerdy kid
maybe a new home can be an opportunity
to start fresh
i just wish you'd get into some trouble
there's still time
what are you doing here in summerville
anyway we're completely broke and our
grandfather left us this creepy old
farmhouse in the middle of nowhere
your father wasn't much of a homemaker
he could hardly keep the power on
you're saying he left us nothing
well i wouldn't say nothing
[Music]
you went with station wagon it's the
only one that had an engine
what is happening here
somehow
a town with no fault lines is shaking on
a daily basis
maybe it's the apocalypse
egon came out here for a reason
are you troubled by strange noises in
the middle of the night
you experience feelings of dread in your
basement or attic
if you or any of your family ever seen a
spook inspector or ghost
[Music]
oh my god
you guys hear that
something's coming
the whole city
it's like the walking dead
we're ready
we're closed
[Music]
five years ago thanos erased half of the
population of the universe
but the people of this planet brought
everyone back with a snap of a finger
the sudden return of the population
provided the necessary energy
for the emergence to begin
how long do we have
seven days
we're eternals
[Music]
we came here seven thousand years ago
to protect humans from the deviants
why didn't you guys help fight thanos or
any war all the other terrible things
throughout history
[Music]
we were instructed not to interfere in
any human conflicts unless deviants are
involved
by who
[Music]
we need to find the others
i haven't seen some of them for
centuries
hi
hello
this is what the end of the world looks
like
at least we have front row seats
you know what's never saved the planet
you're sarcasm
we have loved these people since the day
we arrived
when you love something
you protect it
[Applause]
you can't protect
[Music]
any of them
[Music]
i bet you've built the perfect safe
house what's this even made of vibranium
fall collection
ikea
[Music]
i'm sorry brother
sorry that i brought you into this i
just wanted things to be the way they
used to be
that's my brother will i could use some
help my wife needs to search me this is
real life how's that right you put your
life down on the line for this country
you leave your family your home how much
do you need
231.
how about more
32 million and i need an extra man i
came to you for a loan look have i ever
gotten you anything that i couldn't get
you out of it's time for you to do
something for your family
what can i do for officer we're just
doing a transfer from the back i'll let
you in 20 minutes uh if i could just get
it down real quick because i'm on the
clock promise not to rob the place
seriously because that would be bad for
my job
my brother okay all right all right
[Music]
you are all gonna have the greatest
story to tell at dinner tonight
lock everything down
nothing gets out
[Music]
just gonna borrow it i got a cop shot i
gotta get him to the hospital i'm gonna
need you to help us why don't you help
us we're doing hostages now
we're not crashing into this ambulance
we got a brother cop on board do you
have emt experience combat's reaction
you're a soldier
you think you're so tough with that gun
no daddy relax
i gotta get back to my life with my son
does your wife know you're all banks
well not the bad
guys we're just the guys trying to get
home
we don't get to walk off into the sunset
danny everybody knows how dangerous you
are do you
you get your heroes out of here now
i'm gonna get you back home little
brother i'm gonna get everybody home
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
league of super pet i love it perfect
hey
pets plural
you ever heard of a league with one dude
in it
i have it well they say i'm in a league
of my own oh you're the leaguer you own
all right mm-hmm ain't nobody as messed
up as you
next summer dwayne johnson is crypto
kevin hart has ace
how much did you have to drink
many years ago
this candle blessed our family with a
miracle
our house our casita came to life with
magic
[Music]
in time every member of our family
cecilia
was given their own magical gifts
uh-huh i understand you
i'm not super strong
the donkeys got out again
or effortlessly perfect like senorita
perfect
but my mom
why am i the only one that didn't get a
gift you're just as special as anyone
else in this family
you just healed my hand with the nade
pacon queso
what's going on
the magic is in danger we gotta get out
of here we must protect our home we must
protect our family
this is my chance i will save the magic
wait
how do i save the magic
[Music]
let me help you
the rats told me everything don't eat
those
even in our darkest moments
there's light
where you least expect it
[Music]
but at least i'll have a friend nope he
flew away immediately quitter
[Music]
all right whenever you're ready
we are shooting a documentary because i
am about to meet my first biological
relative
she's amish i'm not i am not awkward
we are humbled and grateful to have our
sister margot return to us
i've always hoped that i could meet you
all so this is a really special moment
for me
hey
mind if i film you for a moment
[Music]
i like your doll what's her name
yeah
you know that was my mom's name
she used to live here a long time ago
she's still here
[Music]
what did she say
[Music]
whoa
why would they build a church all the
way back here
what is that the demon asmodeus was
trapped inside a chosen woman of god
this has happened before
what the hell
are these from my mom
you can't have me and my baby
i know everybody's family within a
50-mile area
they think amish
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh my god are you sure about this i have
to know
[Music]
it was the night before christmas
vacation
and the fun was in full swing you split
our family onto two separate flights mom
please the family left for their big
vacation is that everyone the cars are
leaving now but forgot one little thing
mum
dad uncle blake
they don't even know i'm here
they don't even know i'm here
my mum and dad have gone to tokyo i'm
totally on my own
[Music]
you do realize that my ten-year-old son
is at home by himself you just assumed
max was on the other flight we didn't
take a census
we got reports of suspicious people
around 36 lincoln have
i can't go to jail honey i wouldn't last
30 seconds in gen pop that's where fresh
fish get got nobody here is getting guts
and we're criminals i don't think so
this is my house i have to defend it
orange stripe center pocket
[Music]
that did not sound right
i am trying to get home to my son
who is alone
i'm scared
i'm that stupid
[Music]
yes i do
only on disney plus
[Music]
uncle casey can't just stay for one
night
one night
[Music]
really
how big is he gonna get that depends on
how much you love him
clifford how did this happen
[Music]
that's a big red dog
you know i'm a little better why don't
you take his temperature where in the
animal temperature taking place
[Music]
it's all over the internet there's a 10
foot dog in upper manhattan that can't
be real we are offering a 25 000 reward
for the capture of the big red dog
people don't like things that are
different
there are no other dogs like you what's
he doing i think he's trying to be small
[Music]
what do we do we have to save him i'm in
we're in
really everything
[Music]
your dog just saved my life
i'm getting clifford out of here you
know how to drive how hard can it be
[Music]
well
[Music]
i'll be home in the morning where are
you going i'm staying over at susie's
tonight
what's new
the flyer
the papers call him the grabber i wish
one combat you don't actually believe
that story do you because he can't hear
you and he doesn't really take kids that
say
oh
beautiful isn't that just peachy cute
you need some help you see that
would you hand me my hat
yes sir
i
am a part-time
are those magician of loads in there
would you like to see a magic trick
i have an announcement to make one of
our students finney blake was abducted
what if i could help the police find
penny
[Applause]
[Music]
does it work
not since i was a kid
i'll scream i'll scratch your face
this face
daddy i had a dream about it what
happened in your dream he was taken by a
man with black balloons yes we never
release those details
[Music]
please please let the dreams be real see
the wall in front of you i tore a long
cable loose from down there
there's a combination lock on the inside
of the storm door what's the combination
i carved it in the wall
the tree the door the gate i've never
seen you before except in my dreams
you don't have much time
you're gonna use a weapon you raise the
phone step back and swing
look what you made me do
please hurry you remember what i told
you
there's someday i should stand up for
myself someday it's today fans
once there was a place in the woods
where they sent people who didn't fit
into the real world welcome jacob
species identity disorder can be cured
so that a person who thinks themselves
an animal
can resume a happy healthy
and rewarding life i want to do it
it's the best thing for everyone
[Music]
you're all gonna end up wonderful human
beings
they say the wolf and the wildcat are
natural enemies
but they're wrong
how long have you been here
since i can remember
[Music]
you call him the zookeeper
keep clear of him
everything's running away
only one person ever did
i've always had this feeling
these instincts
stop
you're gonna get us caught
i can't it's a cool cruel world
once upon a time
there was a wolf
and a wild cat
i wanted to live happily ever after
it's not just about surviving but
surviving is me
do you really think you can have a life
with that boy
[Music]
but life is no fairy tale
is it
[Music]
do you want things to get worse for you
i have no human form i have no human
form
jacob
what have they done to you
[Music]
[Music]
apparently it's very difficult to access
at the bottom of this part of the lake
there's a perfectly preserved house
let's go
there she is
[Music]
[Music]
what is that
what can i say fellas when i leave
you'll be missed
[Applause]
beautiful olga
will you let me hold you
you go first
[Music]
attention attention dear comrades the
people city council informs you that due
to an incident at the turnover nuclear
power plant there is an adverse
radioactive situation in the city of
pripyat
[Music]
the reactor is in a subcritical state as
you all know if enough fuel burns
through and gets to the water there will
be a steam explosion full of radioactive
material the contamination of
uncontained will spread to kiev moscow
and all of western europe
right so we have to get the water out
the volunteers will receive payment
[Music]
we're talking dirty water in a confined
space not a clean swimming pool all your
engineers just won't cut it
i'm going back down you won't survive
again
we have no authority to order it
do you really want to risk the citizens
of kiev getting ready for the mayday
celebration
[Music]
remember that story that they told us
about in
training about george washington's first
female spy during the revolution
they called her agent 355
because they didn't want the world to
know her real name
but her legacy lives on
[Music]
but now we have a common enemy
they can start world war three
from simple reach of their keyboard so
we need to join
it's like half forces cia's most wanted
always such a tough guy
i'm not an agent i'm a therapist they
thought it would give you my secrets do
you have secrets
we put ourselves in danger so that
others are not
i'll handle the guns
are you in therapy they should be
you're the best in the world of what you
do you have cameras in your jewelry
comes in your earrings you bump i
the grab is on the move you're not going
in there alone we go together
i have a family i cannot do this anymore
the bad guys are out there right now
you go home
you bring them with you
are you under control are you no
black card all black everything i've got
four more agents out on the street i
counted six but thanks for the tip
i like the new team we're the 355.
[Music]
in five weeks a hundred thousand british
forces will strike sicily southern shore
unfortunately the nazis know of our
intentions
so we're going to play a humiliating
trick on hitler
[Applause]
we have to convince germany that our
target is greece the plan begins in
spain where the corpse will wash up on
shore bearing classified letters a
corpse carrying fake documents
giving the fascist network there we
could quite literally float the
documents right into enemy hands
prime minister that's too big a risk the
fate of the world is at stake the plan
is highly implausible
so when can it be ready
well let's say we start with the easy
part and find ourselves a corpse
the thing is the german scrutinizer
every detail of our fallen man
where are his legs
he must be as real as your eye he would
carry a letter from his wife professing
her deep love for him very good
and he would carry her photograph my
contribution to the mission for a seat
at the table
although
what if the autopsy reveals he didn't
die of drowning
or if the briefcase is returned to us
without the germans seeing its contents
charles why on earth do you keep poking
holes in our plan i'm preemptively
poking
success depends
on guiding the papers into hitler's
hands
the nightmare marching this way is only
too real in the spanish we play the
germans anywhere near our briefcase we
are in the dark if the enemy is waiting
for us on those beaches
history herself will avert her eyes from
the slaughter
i may vomit
i may vomit with you
in stories of war there is that which is
seen and that which is hidden
[Music]
in god's name fleming what are you
writing
spy story
in the hidden war the truth
is protected by a bodyguard of lies
its soldiers unseen
prey its heroes unsung
this
is our war
i got these two great tennis players
all we need
is a club
everything to go from prodigy to pro
race your hand surrender venus williams
what you think
nobody's taking that bat
tennis takes expert instruction
it takes families with unlimited
financial resources
it's like asking somebody to believe
that you got the next two mozarts in
your house
venus and serena gonna shake up this
world
go to the sky
yeah that's it there you go
they're not going wimbledon like this
now we're hearing me on those raggedy
courts
we just got to stick to the plan we got
champions in another room
you call them always
richard i'm impressed i think you might
just have the next michael jordan
oh no brother man i guess me the next
too
let me ask you about something what do
you want under this i know what your dad
wants but what about you well i wonder
when you went in as many times as
anyone's ever wanted you think you can
do that
every american player got good following
this path we're going to do this a
different way
you pulled them out of juniors now you
pull them out of practice you do it
constantly i'm trying to look out for my
kids you're looking out for yourself
this is their life
you gotta let them decide
venus williams
what you want blessed show all those
people that i can handle what's coming
[Music]
you are a champion
in the whole world
she's playing the best player on the
planet she can't beat her
but what if she do nobody
[Music]
i have never been more proud
let me see your dangerous face
that's your dangerous [ __ ] make some
dangerous noises
that's your dangerous face
okay don't do that for the people
[Music]
thomas ernest
mother ex-cop
convicted of murder in a burglary gone
wrong
apex is quite simple
their hunters
you are the prey
what's the price if i kill all the
hunters
win and i can guarantee your freedom
[Music]
my good hunter
welcome find me a real challenge
who the hell is that
do we get a refund if we kill this guy
within an hour
you're good kid i'm better than good i'm
bacon and eggs on sunday morning
malone has defied death more times than
most navy seals
simply put
the universe just can't seem to kill him
men like that never should have come to
a place like this
let's remind malone who is the hunter
and who is the prey
i win that's all i do
that won't be happening
bring me the head of thomas malone
your only logical choice is to beg
beg me to let you live
this ain't that kind of fight even
better
you're a freak
freak
[Music]
my dearest friend be very angry with you
if you died
my sole purpose on this earth is to love
roxanne does she know the world will
never accept someone like me and a tall
beautiful woman
we have no money a clever marriage is
your only option i won't be rescued i'm
not in distress love does that mean
nothing to you children need love adults
need money
i need something to die for
write poems and cry for
and i won't be
ashamed
i'd give anything
for someone to say
that they can't live without me and
they'll be there forever
i have a confession to make i am madly
in love perhaps he feels the same but
i've never actually spoken to him of
your love i think
he is christian christian
he's a new recruit your regiment of
course he is a woman like roxanne wants
wit romance poetry i don't know how to
speak romantically i am a poet my words
upon your lips
i will make you romantic will you make
me handsome she loves me
[Music]
[Applause]
speak to me like you do in your letters
you are a beautiful flower i am not a
flower
my fate is to love her from afar
[Music]
we must let her decide our fate she must
have the choice
[Music]
told your mother i can take good care of
you
[Music]
i love you more than anyone in this
whole wide world
[Music]
her mom was dead
she'll be better off here no she won't
what's her name
you can call her whatever you want
you'll be my little angel from now on
[Music]
angel
how did you end up with this place
she doesn't talk about her past
you got any plans
plans
[Music]
she can't keep me here
you forget where i found you missy
i made you a princess
feel the power
the only girls who leave here are too
old too sick to work
they're dead
i'm gonna kill you
you are not hitting
it's just something to see ain't she
there's never been a moment
no one gets within a foot of hurt for
free
i have to meet him
what's your pleasure mister i didn't
come here for that i hear
[Music]
take me away from here
give me the life i deserve
i've got too many demons i don't know
how to love
you did not she lose the life you have
but you can't choose enough you won't
[Music]
he deserves a decent girl not you
did you think i couldn't find you
you have to stop thinking that i'm gonna
be something that i'm not
that way it's home
your choice
i will rescue
you
[Music]
it takes more than guns to kill amir
you think i'm your enemy
i am your enemy
but your enemy won't be gone when you
kill me
your brother is still in prison
your twin brother was an anarchist
my brother was a revolutionary
somebody was up to something i wanted to
be a part of it
ask help from no one
where is he
cameraman is my brother
he almost 10 minutes on the street
knowing what he knows
this is a battleground
who's the contact
russia goodbye tell me so when is this
gonna happen it has happening for a
thousand years
we had a deal
your brother can expose everything
i have done what is mine to do
the world is watching what happens here
it's on
is he here now i would lie myself on
fire
how come no one is lighting themselves
on fire
where's my brother
[Music]
[Music]
listen young lady but a friend is
nowhere to be seen how'd you become such
a hot actually walk through history
that's what i'm meant to do
to the seats with the clearest view
then she's hooked to the silver screen
do you know who i am yeah do you know
who my girlfriend is robert scheissen
barbra streisand
sand yeah like sands like the ocean like
harvest sand
no but stray sand sand
but the bell is
[Music]
do you really want to see my boobs
can i touch them
see you tomorrow
[Music]
i think it's weird hanging out with gary
and his friends all the time
i think it's weird that i hang out with
gary and his 15 year old friends all the
time
[Music]
just like you're not gonna forget me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
action
[Music]
hello
[Music]
[Music]
your grandfather is a selfish old prick
who resents taking care of his family
and yet you all end up back here at my
house welcome i'm your only uncle what's
the most of your favorite outfit right
sounds like something
i have no idea how you are going to law
school so you can sue your father for
child support no so he can help with
your fines about the septic tank no here
we go
hey who's kid is that my sister which
sister is a hot woman crazy what do you
want to die
[Music]
[Applause]
i'll take care of you teach the male
sciences i saw you in the yard playing
sports you're not very good find some
other activities i like to read
you read enough for those maybe
you could become a writer one more thing
very important never hit a woman
even if she stabs you with scissors
today my nephew is officially a man
[Applause]
it is a great pleasure to offer you a
place in the yale class of 1986.
hey i'm jr sydney you're in my class
i doubt it
well i'm on my way
so what do you want to be j.r i'm going
to be a writer
what's your main theme the absent father
poor boy who wants a rich girl
she doesn't love you
what you do next is going to be
important
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what are you gonna do without the bad
guy in your life
in life
you gotta have it
if you don't have it
you never get it
and i say you got it
will you renfield take this woman
hi what is it you are wanting
you
what is that girl doing here she's some
sort of monster hunter
your new targets are messy the loch ness
monster and yeti
the snow monster of the himalayas we
have to stop her max no prepare me for
the fight mom he's gonna turn us all
into monsters again on this magical
monster night
great job max but how can we save them
if we don't know where they are i can
find anyone with this party people
disappear
[Music]
and stronger
it's not too late to change your mind
out of my way
over here
that doesn't work on me i am perfect
[Music]
don't worry i've got you
i'm so glad no one knows me out here
you are all crazy
okay that's not good
[Music]
emergency at the chemical factory no
georgia girls aren't allowed to be
firemen but i'm as brave as any boy
it's my dream it's my destiny
girls can't be firemen give me a break
extra arsonist breaks again
the firemen who go into the theaters
they don't come out
i need you to run the fire investigation
i'll need a team here's the plan i
joined dad's team egg crate for the
stomach muscles mango for the biceps
and for the mustache
oh okay too much
[Music]
let me introduce you the brains of your
operation ricardo
uh ginger driver fastest cabbie in
manhattan
who are you me uh i'm joe i'm fireman
joe slow down joe did you even check the
it's funny
you remind me of my daughter really yeah
that is funny
yeah she wanted to be a fireman too
so why didn't you teach her what you're
teaching me she's my daughter i love her
and i worry about her every second of my
life
i catch the arsonist i'll have to change
the rules then i'll be the first fireman
woman the job is far too dangerous
maybe this is a sign that it's time you
follow your own dreams
i never gave up on mine
[Music]
the mustache is very convincing it's my
dog's butt
hair oh
looking forward to this all day
come on let's go
go where my new hiding place
[Music]
hey hold on
[Music]
oh my gosh what is this they're just
like us
they walk up right
[Music]
they
are what we used to be mostly the
uprights could be out there somewhere if
you don't take a chance now
this is warfare he's a track
hello are you upright we didn't think
there were any orphans left this is
amazing
it was because of men that our ancestors
fled or stayed behind and we changed no
hands look at this
you can take them off
it's just a trick
my family's waiting for me
you gotta help me maybe we can
the hunter you distract me
look at me the distraction what are you
doing
oh boy
come to rescue
us we stand with you mostly
[Applause]
there's something noble inside of you
mostly
something worth fighting for
[Music]
first of all this is a journal not a
diary tomorrow is the first day of
middle school luckily i'm not alone in
this middle school thing i've got my
best friend rally
here's what you need to know watch where
you sit on the first day of school don't
use the bathroom on the second floor and
finally don't
get the cheese touch
because if you do you might as well be
dead
thank you roderick for that wonderful
pep talk
we're out of our league here maybe my
mom can homeschool me
hey greg wanna come over and
play play play
[Music]
yep i'm pretty sure i'm gonna be in
therapy over this
we're in middle school now don't you
think it's time distracting our age
frankly wanna see my
secret freckle i'm like permanently
scarred from that night look at these
little nerds i'll pass their bedtime
[Music]
disgusting
[Music]
but for now stuck in middle school
surrounded by morons
if you just stick with me everything
will be fine
oh sorry
i i thought you were teenagers are you
all right
you're all right
[Music]
[Music]
huh
[Music]